[Music]
the scp foundation specializes in
tracking anomalous creatures entities or
objects and protecting mankind by
keeping these anomalies contained it
doesn't happen very often though that an
scp surrenders itself to the foundation
offering to be contained without putting
up a fight you might think that that
would be a welcome change for the
foundation's personnel getting an easy
containment like that rather than having
to devote valuable time resources and
even lives to capturing an anomaly but
then you have to ask the obvious and
worrying questions how did this anomaly
know where to find the foundation so
that it could turn itself in in the
first place did somebody send it and if
so why well don't worry you don't need
to try and imagine this scenario because
an scp turning itself over to the
foundation under mysterious
circumstances has actually already
happened one day security personnel at
an scp foundation containment site
opened the front door to find an scp
just sitting there on the doorstep the
anomaly was brought in for questioning
and while it was soon designated scp-032
it has sometimes been known by another
name brother's bride scp-032 is a person
or rather a replica of a person not a
living statue that moves whenever you
look away or a wax work that comes to
life when the sun goes down no this
replica is far stranger
scp-032 resembles a human woman around
30 years of age who made her who she is
supposed to resemble and just where
exactly she came from are all still
questions the foundation have been
unable to answer but what the research
teams have been able to determine is
what she is made from brother's bride
consists largely of plastics at least
the external portion of her body her
skin is made from a combination of 5.5
millimeter thick silicone and other
plastic fiber polymers all colored with
a pigment to more closely mimic the
shade of caucasian human skin
scp-032 has been referred to as a type f
human simulacrum by the foundation
meaning that she has an imperfect
outward resemblance to a human being and
the internal workings of her body are
drastically different from an ordinary
human's organs or central nervous system
what does scp-032 have instead while she
lacks any skeleton or any of the other
internal parts that make up a human body
instead her insides are entirely refined
liquid oil however in spite of having no
bones no organs and existing as just
pure oil filling up a plastic skin
scp-032 has no problem moving on her own
or communicating verbally when she was
first discovered waiting outside the
foundation's slovakian compound brothers
bride claimed that she had come there to
be stored
scp-032 is imperfect in how closely she
resembles a human being and this becomes
more apparent the closer one gets to her
at a distance she can maintain some
illusion of appearing to be fully human
however her appearance becomes less and
less convincing as someone approaches
naturally the sight of an uncanny
rubbery almost human is enough to
unsettle someone perhaps even cause
discomfort but this also happens to be
unrelated to scp-032's anomalous
abilities which she detailed to
foundation personnel when she was first
contained the foundation security team
that discovered scp-032
patiently sitting and waiting to be
found questioned her motives and how she
had come to be there there was no record
of what time she might have arrived on
the compound security cameras and
scp-032 gave the personnel no inkling as
to how she knew the location of the
foundation's slovakian site somehow
she'd managed to approach without being
spotted by anyone but would not explain
how she had done so security personnel
at the site were obviously skeptical and
asked brothers bride why she had come to
the foundation
scp-032 claimed that her creators had
commanded her to that she was to be
placed in indefinite storage until
claimed although the silicon-based woman
appears to possess a normal level of
cognitive function she claims that she
is not fully sapient meaning scp-032
does not possess the intelligence or
understanding of other human beings at
least according to her by her own
admission
scp-032 is an intermediary acting on
behalf of her creators although the scp
foundation has yet to be able to verify
this as for her anomalous abilities
scp-032 was kind enough to detail these
to the security personnel that first
found her she has an innate ability to
influence any biological entity in her
immediate vicinity in other words any
organism that gets too close well not
quite any there is a limitation to her
power
scp-032 can only affect a creature or
organism not created by related to or
influenced by humanity so plants animals
even microorganisms like bacteria all
fall into the category of things that
scp-032 has an effect on according to
the various tests the foundations
researchers have conducted the exact
nature of how scp-032's abilities work
seems to vary but her presence always
causes massive and irreversible damage
to an animal or organism's ability to
exchange or use energy for example when
scp-032 is surrounded by wild flora
these plants will lose the ability to
conduct the process of photosynthesis
they therefore can no longer produce or
consume energy preventing them from
continued growth and ultimately causing
death in much the same vein any animals
that come into close contact with
scp-032 will find themselves unable to
use their respiratory or digestive
systems rendering them unable to breathe
oxygen or properly consume food not even
germs and other microorganisms are safe
from
scp-032's effects although when it comes
to these microscopic life forms her
ability seems to focus solely on their
reproductive systems and if bacteria
cannot divide itself it cannot spread at
present the scp foundation keeps
brother's bride housed in an automated
containment unit restricting the amount
of direct contact personnel can have
with her unless they are there to
conduct authorized experiments or other
necessary research related tasks staff
are to leave
scp-032 alone any interviews with her
are not even carried out in person and
instead researchers use a remote
communication array to ask scp-032 more
about her origin her creators and her
abilities this probably seems a little
over cautious right after all scp-032
has no effect on the human body and
isn't aggressive or outwardly hostile
maybe locking her in a room is excessive
but remember her degenerative abilities
do affect microorganisms and bacteria
even those that are beneficial to human
beings the human body is full of good
bacteria that aids with digestion and
helps the body absorb nutrients like the
ones you've heard about and ads for
probiotic yogurt since zero three two's
effects don't discriminate between good
and bad bacteria people have to keep
their distance from scp-032
or else they might find that they can no
longer digest food properly in fact no
biological material is allowed anywhere
near her no houseplants no pets nothing
oddly scp-032 herself seems fine with
this and has never expressed any desire
for any form of comfort and does not
appear to require sustenance like food
or water shortly after she was first
contained by the scp foundation
scp-032 was interviewed by dr alexander
kovac the resident psychologist at the
site where brothers bride was discovered
dr kovac initially tried to ask scp-032
to disclose her name however she was
unable to do so i don't have one people
have names i'm not one she then went on
to explain that even her creators had no
name for her and that she was instructed
to cooperate with the scp foundation dr
kovac pressed on asking about when she
told security that she was to be stored
until collected who scp-032 had meant
was coming to collect her her answer was
as enigmatic as could be expected she
claimed that she was going to be
collected by someone her creators wished
to torment and finding her in the hands
of the scp foundation would bring this
person greater suffering kovac asked if
this person was part of the foundation
assuming that scp-032's creators had
some kind of animosity towards a
particular member of personnel and that
0-3-2 was part of some kind of revenge
plot against a member of foundation's
staff
scp-032 denied this though stating he is
not one of you merely a one-time
sympathizer of sorts he believes you
tried to help him once and if he is
forced here if he finds me here you will
die that will hurt him they have no
interest in any of you or your
organization you are here as a tool just
as i am according to scp-032 the man
coming to collector was a prideful
complacent figure who won when he should
have lost somehow this individual had
apparently been punished by being forced
to live in exile from his kin and wander
the world endlessly destroying anything
in his path yet unwillingly his very
presence would poison human beings
leaving this man trapped in eternal
solitude tormented by the weight of his
guilty conscience
scp-032 described the man's punishment
as a masterwork of torment she described
her purpose in being sent to the
foundation as being to act as this man's
last undoing apparently this wanderer
would occasionally find solace in
looking at nature and find hope in the
world around him her ability to destroy
the organisms around her would be a way
to break this man's will and the final
nail in the proverbial coffin apparently
scp-032's appearance was also seemingly
meant to deceive him she stated that the
man would recognize her and this would
remind him of fond memories but then as
he got closer he would see scp-032 for
what she really was a crude replica of a
human being reminding this man that her
likeness would be forever out of his
reach
scp-032 was intended by her creators to
be as artificial as the wandering man's
hope and when he eventually found her
either in a day a month or in a century
she would destroy his very last source
of solace at the conclusion of the
interview dr kovac asked why this man
would recognize her and scp-032 simply
replied i used to be his wife if we take
scp-032 at her word then it appears she
was created with the intention of being
used to torment this wandering man and
act as a final punishment for him in
another interview six months after her
initial containment
scp-032 expressed a hatred for the man's
wife whom she was made to resemble sent
in to assess
scp-032's cognitive abilities and
personality or lack of dr kovac
questioned this
scp-032 had always been adamant that she
had no conscious thoughts or feelings of
her own and when challenged by the
doctor she claimed that she hated her
mold because her creators wanted her to
the first thing scp-032's creators had
done after making her was show her the
wife of the man they hoped to torment it
is unclear whether scp-032 was shown
photographs or the actual woman she had
been molded from not an easy task as
this woman the wife was apparently long
dead but the creators had risked
disturbing the wife's final rest just to
show her to scp-032
she was beautiful so peaceful serene
whole even gone even dead i could see
the essence of who she used to be of who
she still was and forever will be her
soul they told me she didn't get to live
for all that long but when she lived she
was herself she was alive and so i hated
her in the wife's face
scp-032 saw a reflection of herself and
realized that she had been made just to
be a mockery a parody of a living human
being existing only to cause misery to
the wandering man who would one day find
her instead of skin she had molded
silicone and plastic synthetic fiber in
place of hair and oil for blood but what
scp-032 lacked she realized was a soul
this was all part of the brother's
design according to scp-032
when the man found her he would see not
only what had been done to the memory of
his wife but he'd also see how much
scp-032
hated her and hated herself for not
being alive the same way the wife had
been the goal of all this to make the
man realize that he never won
scp-032 herself is a mystery but perhaps
the real question is who do you think
this man is and what was it he didn't
win but that's a story for another day
let us know what you think down in the
comments now go check out
scp-5545 mysterious tunnels in
antarctica abnormality and
scp-1730 what happened to site 13 the
full story compilation for more of the
most mysterious scps